[Music]
I'm working 12 hours a day getting $6 an
hour because I'm undocumented still
people say that I'm a terrorist I've
been living in constant fear of
deportation for 13 years now I've been
here since I was four
America's all I know now I'm terrified
of being sent back to a country I don't
know I've been feeling depressed because
I don't know if my hard work is going to
amount to anything
since I'm undocumented I hide my
undocumented status from my significant
other because I don't want him thinking
I'll use him to get a green card I would
cry myself to sleep because people
thought I was a bad person for not
having documents I'm not a bad person
if I would have stayed in the country I
came from I would have already been dead
by now I've always wanted to join the
military and fly a fighter jet but I
can't even enlist because I'm
undocumented I feel like no one
understands all the secrets I have to
hide and I struggle to make friends
because of it I refuse to let my
undocumented status define who I am
[Music]
you
[Music]